but time I can see the comments now I
know just remember a YouTube movie
reviewer randomly talking about a
trailer it's never late
no Jose but sometimes he does fall into
a porn vortex on the computer for a
couple days get you a video a little
late jump I don't even know if you guys
are Dell I got two days ago you guys
like talked about it I think now you're
like whatever if you do do you want to
talk about it so we got a new trailer
for Independence Day resurgence and we
see in this one what we saw in the last
one which is we have taken the fallen
alien technology and combined it with
our own to make superhuman technology we
had 20 years to prepare but so did they
now the aliens have come back with more
troops a bigger ship and hopefully some
security firewall seriously if our
computer software was compatible in 1995
you bet that shit's compatible now we're
using their stuff throw like we're back
him ends and now we have Windows 10 we
didn't want to upgrade but dr. Peter
just made us it was weird guys Will
Smith Steven Hiller and he's dead
him here he died we see his tragic death
in this trailer now this is a story off
[ __ ] dead I Will Smith which I totally
get
imagine he's like yeah back in the 90s I
wanted to be in this because Fresh
Prince was ending and disaster movies
were really huge it was a big career
move smart career move now he's like but
I don't need it no I don't need it Bill
Pullman Jeff Goldblum yeah they're back
it's funny because Bill Pullman is back
he has a couple great things to say some
Bill Pullman ish presidential things
like when it was like we don't have a
fighting chance he's like we didn't last
time either negative instruction holy
all right in the last trailer you saw
that huge ship just devouring is not
devouring the earth is flying over it
but it's so huge I just like the clouds
are vaporizing you can tell us it's
drawing everything cuz why my reaction
videos like everyone's dead so I just
feel like everywhere this ship goes
something it's all burning and we see it
has its own gravitational force so it's
picking up buildings and [ __ ] and
dropping it and see where someone's like
it landed in the Atlantic where it's
pretty big dude I feel like the earth is
dead either way like everything's gonna
be disrupted and destroyed and why are
we even fighting
we're dead either way I feel like things
are just gonna be kind of [ __ ] after
that but I will say if that scene that's
been in both trailers where Bill Pullman
dies I'm gonna be pissed
we already saw the heartbreaking tragic
dramatic death of will
Smith in this trailer ah [ __ ] dead I
don't want to see Bill Pullman to do
don't do that to me I'm just driving to
conclusions though I don't know what it
is mine up baby it's the YouTuber in me
we all have a bad history with trailers
ruining movies I wanna have a big ship
got there though alright we have their
alien technology you would say that
comes with a pretty solid radar attached
to it right so I'm going to see cloaked
ships what how did that thing get there
I did just sneak past our security like
yeah your security sucks by the way or
was that thing just there hanging out
for the past twenty years like yeah we
see what's going on waiting actually I
think that's it because you see alien
skulls like I've been there a while I
could just live there who has your sad
or not to see them I understand earths
pretty big but I just feel like someone
out there would have a Geiger counter
they're not a Geiger counter but a
Geiger counter mixed with their
technology maybe hey suborn is
Independence Day resurgence looks absurd
does that mean bad no it looks like
roland emmerich absurd the only bummer I
kind of feel right now from the trailer
that I'll probably feel in the movie is
the fact that it's not our world really
independence day one was cool because
everyone was going about their day to
day in a world that we know and then the
aliens show up and start wiping it out
in this one they have souped up
technology combined with alien
technology is not even our recognizable
world anymore so we'll see what happens
so the new Independence Day resurgence
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more